you've become this good vibe you got
this whole good vibe tribe going with
you now like
every time i see your instagram you're
just feeling good you're living like
it's almost like you're like jimmy
buffett's stepson or something you know
like
you're just having a good time you know
like yeah it seems like you're loving
life you know what do you think
is some of the stuff that's going on and
maybe some stuff you've been talking
about
yeah i'm just happier with with
reality i guess i don't know what you
can say but i'd be lying if i sat up
here and said um i don't have bad days
you know we all have bad days but i felt
like in the last couple years i've been
able to
get more use of slapping myself back in
shape you know and just and seeing the
better things
just staying in a place of gratitude
like we've spoke before about i feel
like it's easier for me to do that
because i have so much to be thankful
for and grateful for
and uh i'm happy about those things you
know i just gotta
if i do have those days where i'm kind
of down or overworked or
i just you know i get to do this i don't
have to and i'm happy that i'm in a
position to do it and
and like you said with the foundation
and stuff like that i'm i have so much
good things
and and so much positivity on my back
that i'm carrying that i just use that
as momentum
in every day i feel i just feel good man
i'm happy with the guy i look at in the
mirror
and i think that's most important it's
inspiring man i mean you've definitely
honestly really inspired me over the
years man i appreciate that
that that means a lot to me man and it's
i'm not trying to you know so thank you
that means even more yeah that's what i
think
people say is i'm just i'm just a man
yeah
not the man not he-man yeah and
and i'm happy with the guy and i'm just
trying to do good stuff man and fight
good fights and work as hard as i can
and put my family in a good position and
it's [ __ ] an incredible ride that's
all we can all do man yeah right
um but i think yeah i think that's what
some of the inspiration is it's like you
just see somebody doing kind of like
what we can all do if we you know get up
and stay focused and apply ourselves i
feel like that's what the vibe that i
get thank you man
um i'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could i be so far from my
[Music]
and my mind is somewhere else but when i
find it i'll patch up where it's been